a design flaw news submitted by meatloaf
eating meat loaf McDonald's Japan
accidentally created very sexually
suggestive beverage accidentally
everybody [ __ ] sent me these man so
yeah dolls Japan had a sweet idea to
promote its new summertime make fizz
drinks create clear cups with the boy on
one side and a girl on the other that
once emptied show a boy and a girl
innocently kissing each other this cute
yeah it's not bad is not offensive and
it's very nice how did you [ __ ] that up
but when customers began tilting cups at
different angles and drinking them and
finishing them the romance turn hot and
heavy it's beautiful yeah that's a full
cup how innocent it's empty pickup but
it's at an angle yeah so cute oh very
cute she's jacking him off while he's
kissing him no she's not that's very
innocent okay
I mean she's kidding oh wait wait wait
wait
big big big big how does the cup doing
this angles they just turn it rotating
you're looking upwards that the cup
right now like this one it's a naughty
cup no they're clearly drawing on this
you have no imagination clearly drawing
on the cup this is crazy think back to
when you were child yes Rose same cup is
all the other cups no no there's
different wine other different artwork
the same designs but different artwork
okay so only certain cups with like yeah
he's yeah different positions so like is
this one does that one do anything funny
like this no he's like sitting on some
imaginary bench or some thought that was
jacking them off no she's a gigolo why's
he grabbed his junk yeah that she's
jacking off yeah yeah yeah yeah this one
she's kissing in jacking off like yeah
yeah and he's a little boy he's tiny so
she's a giant chicken he's a little boy
mine's made me and J long time
my favorite this one is this how you
really people are not drawing these no
dick manufacturers have made it like
this
the different designs and at Oulton
about this one I like this one cuz he
had to jump he looked like he jumped up
cuz his arms are like straight up he
like jumped up into the air and then
shoved
he's like a dolphin just sticking his
dick in his or in her mouth I don't
understand what is going on the stripes
why this is when when a girl puts her
dick in your mouth that's called sucking
on your dick no maybe look at it from if
you look at it from this angle
yeah if you look at it from this angle
or that angle it changes the view yeah
you're stacking the image listen the
first image that we saw was a girl
holding a hat and a guy like oh no no
cuz there's a different there are all
different cups there's like three or
four different go back to the other one
you just didn't can see now that same
organism so that's the original one
she's not holding happiness and then but
what do you see healthier than the head
sights going down lower to the torso and
then this one she's just holding a half
different designs yeah so you don't see
the Hat here but that's the kissing one
go back go back to the other kissing
line yeah that's what it should normally
look like right but then this one see
right here so you know had here you know
to me is that there's a whole team of
people that are there working on this
stuff and testing it and there wasn't a
single human that was a psychic moment
they were like we did it this created a
viral think we're all talking about
McDonald's right now listen I want to
know which one that one is because
they're not kissing together it's just
one kissing what the [ __ ] is happening
there someone join that one yeah what is
the guy doing
no he's humping along no you know I
can't can we see what the neutral
positions of all these cups are so we
know what they were supposed to look
like and what happens if like let's say
you get Riggins this one three cups now
you have like three dudes and one girl
yeah are they all like bang in the
we're all actually banging each other
perfectly at perfect anal angles yeah I
will say this McDonald's in Japan is
phenomenal it is a really is it really
yeah why it just I don't know like I
don't know what your favorite thing is
they're chicken nuggets the as it tastes
it tastes like the chicken nuggets
here's the chicken nuggets in America
I've been to McDonald's in Denmark and
it was actually better than here would
you get what you get because it's
because it's fresh I got the Big Mac oh
my god it's the same formula for a lot
of [ __ ] like but then out there they
make a fresh yeah oh and then that's the
difference because like so I went to the
McDonald's headquarters and then I got
it made fresh I was like this is how
it's supposed to taste like damn then
it's a hit-or-miss like in the States if
it's fresh that's [ __ ] good if it's
been sitting there for a minute then
it's different but see that's what's so
funny about Nutella corporate
headquarters is like why do people say
our food sucks this is [ __ ] awesome
it's like guys will you hire some of
your employees from the [ __ ] branch
comes to me and and have them try out to
make you some food it's a lot different
oh man I've been at McDonald's during
rush hour and they're like [ __ ]
trying to pump out orders and stuff
right so I've got my food pretty fresh
from McDonald's man and it ain't worth
more than the [ __ ] five bucks I feel
ultimate hack for the French fries if
you order McDonald's and you say I do
not want salt I've got my french fries
they have to do a separate batch for you
and it's fresh and it's fresh B can you
put salt only and then you just put on
your salt later but I'm pretty sure
they're sprinkling crabs on those dog
McDonald's and always been happy after
really never been disbarred really there
has very like he just could just eat
anything fast food very very you know on
occasion rare some might say parts
Chinese and so therefore so like how
often you have fast food
McDonald's maybe I'll be loving once a
month maybe what's the present at
McDonald's yesterday really yeah
I don't touch that [ __ ] really if I'm
like super starving that's why he has a
six-pack and we don't maybe
you're probably the only one that has
like a like a [ __ ] chiseled ass what
do you eat lettuce every day hey
terribly oh yeah so you eat clean or you
eat whatever don't be that guy who has a
6-pack and since I you terribly and I
will fight you right now I promise
listen it's not gonna eat terribly it's
like if I'm that if I don't have meal
preps sometimes I just don't eat I see
you fast
unintentionally you're just under
calories so which work I get me a place
most of the time but on the weekends I
eat pretty much whatever I want
yeah what do you think what do you
what's your splurge your fast food or
whatever
ah no well that's like occasionally but
like I try to cut out cheese dairy
[ __ ] bread like I try just not to eat
those things but I don't know I can't
really uncle Bell no come on when you're
being a bad boy she's playing I'm
splurging [ __ ] spaghetti spaghetti
spaghetti that's it behind me I don't I
don't have like what's your favorite
what's your comfort food you don't have
one you like food no I got a full day I
just I eat well maybe you're not a like
a foodie personality person Oh see I I
like work so much I forget to be I lived
yeah me too same like I can rattle off
every single fast-food order let's do
from every single place yeah if you tell
me the restaurant they're gonna pick up
food out right now I can jump in on that
order I could tell you the number and
exactly what to get cuz I would go to
from oh yeah the same way what's your
favorite fast food down Taco Bell Taco
Bell Taco I've had del Taco I think
twice a moment oh yeah what is what
you're ordering regional like some
places have a lot on the East Coast el
tacos on the East Coast
I think talk about is excellent very
very [ __ ] bomb and Taco Bell I used to
like pop globe Taco Bell is really big
for Indians because they're the only
fast-food place that can you can just
get everything vegetarian burrito taco
beans in it like for any protein so you
can get anything so Indians famously
vegetarian a lot of them are oh yeah a
psycho burnings I've only learned
through you guys a that Chinese people
are seen as trash people buy a lot of
trash yes show that Asian races
that's what they said racist things you
want anal and Chinese kids like India
doesn't like Pakistan Pakistan don't
like any Purdue's first Muslims I've
heard that all of the neighboring Asians
despise each other right but then they
have no [ __ ] opinion about the three
neighbors away you know what Turnham I
heard like not recently but the past
year was jungle Asians all Southeast
Asians are jungle Asians and I was like
what is a jungle Asian know like you
know Asian do you take that as a
derogatory term
I mean I'm Asian but like I don't know
that's why I'll see you as a jungle
Asian have you Filipino and they were
like oh you know like that jungle Asian
I'm like what's a jungle I'm like if you
has a lot of jungles yeah is that is
that what you mean you know like no not
you cuz they you know they use the other
words like there there's like Asian
racism amongst it this no I need to know
about the [ __ ] driving thing I
thought it was like a mean until I Nicky
is like oh my god another Asian driver
and I'm like nah dude racism is not even
racism in Asia it's science yeah they're
Indian no wander okay he's a tiger vs.
dragon who's gonna get the hundred in
math class the Indian kid gets the 99
there's always a Chinese kid who got the
hundred when I'm with me and if the
Chinese kid got the 99 it's always mean
it's always an Indian and Chinese kid at
the [ __ ] spelling bee to just this
year there was an eight-way tie at the
spelling bee or nine way type Wow eight
of them were Indian and then there was
one white chick when I'm when I'm with
my Filipino in-laws all they talk about
is [ __ ] about other Asians and other
racism [ __ ] Mexicans Asians everything
they just way you know you I know right
this is why you know this is why you
know I didn't say anything I heard thank
you when you sit here and you do 600
articles with these [ __ ]
and you're reading like somebody took a
[ __ ] in the street and and these these
cuts are all like Chinese people and
you're just like what and then the
article says that though right
Chinese people I'm like man I'm learning
about things I didn't know that's crazy
you know that mainline Chinese people
take a [ __ ] on the street
like a lot of any people urinate in the
street normally I heard of that in
America no no the Chinese people that
come over here [ __ ] on the street and
they start hissing spitting snot eating
the spitting thing I know is the water
and in their [ __ ] shoot the boogers
out of her what's up I saw that Hong
Kong I was mind blown cuz I'm not here I
know they do it in the sink where's
everyone from zinc right huh where's
everyone's fan I'm from cocky I know I
know where you're Phil I'm Japanese
you're Japanese Cantonese Chinese
Chinese Chinese Chinese Chinese Japanese
they mean yeah I grew up in like a
melting pot of a whole bunch of
different cultures so like where I grew
up it was Native American Japanese
Caucasian in German or that's it well
could you grew up on base to me that's
like little America yeah everyone came
from every place my friends were
Filipino or Indian I didn't go out in
the town every day all right that's true
well is there a culture shock for you
coming into this is an actual real
United States yeah you're born in Japan
no I was in branch man I moved there in
third grade okay so under 8 yeah I was
18 almost yeah oh wow yeah it's like his
whole adolescent is that when you came
back like what were some of the things
that you were driving on the other side
of the road [ __ ] going to the
hospital like in on a military base and
in Japan you go to the hospital and you
get your medicine within the hospital
having to go to [ __ ] Walgreens and
CVS points somewhere else is weird you
can even get medicine for your friend
because he's sick so you just go and
you're like my friend said so this is
the like symptoms and then they'll give
you the yeah
the medicine for how do you weigh in on
the drivers thing cuz my wife says the
Asians are bad drivers and so does so
there's sort of you know I think every
place that's what I thought yeah so
here's the driving racism thing right
okay
so Japanese people follow all the rules
Korean people make up the rules and
Chinese people break all the rules how
you know the difference say it one more
time so Japanese people they follow all
the rules but then they fall it to the
point where it doesn't make sense if
everyone's with the flow of traffic it's
going they're like 65 I'm going 65 on
the [ __ ] dot alright and in Korean
people they'll make up their rules it'll
say 65 and they'll be like I think it's
about 80 you will just break all the
rules and they don't care see for me
that's the white people moms and
minivans and SUVs they make their own
rules alright grandma's [ __ ] don't
even know the rules
you freak all the right grandma I see
you see in India there are no rules like
I'll be driving the opposite side street
but I don't think the Chinese yeah like
you have to because I wouldn't be able
to drive in India oh yeah I'm just
standard average driver I don't thing a
bad yeah it's just terrifying there's so
many people you just say when you get
attacked a cab and they're just driving
on the other side of the road you're
like what the [ __ ] you can't see [ __ ]
yeah there's you know animals homeless
people Costa Rica Bali it's terrifying
to drive terrifying because everyone's
just figuring it out as they go like
motorcycles going like this it's so
confusing have you guys ever been in a
Hong Kong taxi every single time you
feel like you're gonna vomit and they
all have like these little Toyota
kristina's and [ __ ] kind of like 1980s
taxis it's like you're in the fifth
element but you're not flying no
multipass multipass huh
[Music]
[Music]